hi drew i need some design advice from
my friend she's one of the most
thoughtful and generous people i know
betty has owned an irish dance studio in
new york for over 15 years and she
always puts the studio first without
making a big show of it helping students
who can't afford classes or even paying
for their dance costumes and shoes out
of her own pocket
but he is currently working out of her
basement on a makeshift desk because she
had to close the studio during the
pandemic
during hurricane ida everything in the
basement got destroyed
can you please help betty transform her
basement into a functional comfortable
space to work so she can keep on doing
what she does best helping young dancers
fulfill their dreams and seriously since
i'm like since seriously
the new word break out the tissue elise
okay elise and betty are actually in our
audience today yes there's multiple
surprises
[Applause]
on down here please
[Music]
oh my gosh hi betty hi and you may uh
take your mask off
thank you so much betty thank you i'm
gonna kill you
[Laughter]
you know what betty get a little closer
to me because you and i got a lot to
talk about in just a second
um mikal uh you have created something
yes and i am so excited to see what you
have done oh well i hope it lives up to
your expectation i'm a little nervous no
don't be you're so good that's why we
are all here to learn from you okay are
you ready
yes sure this is what it was
oh yeah um remember that i i live that
right now yes
okay how are you take it off all right
you're ready buddy are you ready all
right people let's do it
[Music]
take a look at your new
face
take a look come on in
okay a little bit different huh oh my
gosh
betty why don't you go behind the desk
oh please sit and enjoy and look green
chair nice touch
did you feel the fabric it's velvet
honey yes only the best first velvet
oh macau this is so zen oh my gosh well
you know what so here's the thing first
you have so much storage
with all of these closed doors that you
can store store store and store and all
the beautiful hardware on of course like
that's in the soft clothes honey do that
one more time it's soft clothes yeah
soft clothes macale these are incredible
um this has a lot of great drawers
it's tall enough so it feels substantial
but still leaves space up on the wall to
make a decorative moment yep that's
really smart macau well i mean hey the
thing is the space needed to be
brightened up and speaking of that look
at this rug that we have here this is a
lot lighter than that darker tone that
you had in the space and what i like
about this is not only am i bringing in
a lighter tone but drew you're a texture
girl so when you look at this rug you're
going to see uh varying hues of gray
it's not just like the solid rug that
just kind of goes off into the ground
nobody needs an all-white carpet
unless you live like a hermetic lunatic
it's just not gonna work it's true those
little discrepancies in color help you
live a real life absolutely absolutely
and then another thing is bringing color
and fun like i love neutrals drew loves
color and so it's like how do we mix and
match that and make it come together so
what you're looking at over here is
another uh i like to call it a
functional save typically you would have
had a sofa here but we decided to go
with chairs first because this will give
you some room some flexibility to work
around and it's not so like tight and
claustrophobic anymore and so we're able
to throw in a couple of jewel tone
pillows and now it really feels like
home they also speak to the chair yes
they're tying it in the veil the shape
i love that you went with an open
table that also really helps with
keeping a room breathable absolutely
blocks will block
yes i like blocks with blocks that's a
good one thank you mccall oprah quotable
good mackel likes that how are you
feeling
overwhelmed but very excited
i had no idea surprise yes thank you
very good surprise
um
well i want to thank your friend elise
who um you are definitely going to kill
for all the right reasons oh yeah um
thank you for looking out for your
friend who clearly looks out for others
far beyond herself
and um we were honored to do this with
you today now you're going home with
everything you see in this room
computer to every single thing
[Applause]
furniture
are amazing we're gonna come in and
install it every single thing in here
this is not uh isn't this nice but only
certain things are going everything in
this room from tech to furniture to to
textiles
thank you oh my gosh congratulations i
do love it well
thank you betty thank you so much and
mikael as usual any time any time you
need me and if you don't want these
headphones i'll take them
i'm good thanks this is stunning
[Music]